Bruce Willis is iconic as futuristic cab driver
Korben Dallas in "The Fifth Element" — but what
if a certain "Lethal Weapon" star was
cast instead? From a rock star to a
"Pretty Woman," here are some stars who
nearly appeared in the sci-fi classic.
In an alternate universe, Prince would have
played the role of Ruby Rhod. It's a casting
decision that's pretty much perfect, especially
because Rhod exhibits the eccentricity and
sheer swagger that the "Purple Rain"
artist already possessed. In fact,
director Luc Besson said that he wrote
the Ruby Rhod character specifically
for the Grammy-winning artist.
Besson wrote in a Reddit AMA:
"It was written for Prince. I
met him, he said yes. But then
he went on a world tour for 10 years!!
We couldn't find time in his schedule."
In a Twitter post from 2016, Besson even
shared Jean Paul Gaultier's concept art
of Prince in the role. The famed costume
designer began working with Prince early
on in the film's production, though he
found himself butting heads with the
artist. As part of The Brooklyn Museum's
"The Fashion World of Jean Paul Gaultier:
From the Sidewalk to the Catwalk" exhibit,
Gaultier said this about the singer:
"I showed him my drawings, but he
didn't say a word. [...] Later,
Luc told me that Prince had been
very surprised and amused — by
my presentation, but that he found
the costumes a bit too effeminate."
Ultimately, the role of Ruby Rhod went
to Chris Tucker and the rest is history.
In a separate Reddit AMA, director Luc
Besson revealed that he originally had
Mel Gibson in mind for the role of Korben Dallas.
"You shouldn't tempt me, man."
Besson wrote in the AMA:
"I had asked Mel Gibson first because he had his
office next to mine at Warner Brothers. He peeked
into my office every morning to tell me that he
was thinking about it. After 3 months, he passed."
While it would have been fascinating to envision
Gibson as a futuristic cab driver who helps save
the human race, it's difficult to deny just
how perfect Bruce Willis is in the role. In
a retrospective chat with Entertainment Weekly,
Besson revealed that he was initially hesitant to
reach out to the "Die Hard" actor because
of how costly his fees would be. Willis,
however, was immediately on board
with Besson's vision, saying,
"I just liked Luc — I liked the story,
I liked the idea. I thought it would be
fun to go to France and make a movie."
And money ultimately didn't seem to be an issue
for Willis. As The Hollywood Reporter noted,
the "Sixth Sense" star took a pay
cut to work on "The Fifth Element."
"You want a cup of coffee?"
"Yes, please."
It's hard to imagine anyone else but Milla
Jovovich inhabiting the role of the mysterious
but joyful Leeloo. The heart of the film,
Jovovich expertly captures the raw intensity,
childlike wonder, and naivety that makes
Leeloo such a beloved character. And
for director Luc Besson, meeting Jovovich
was a boon — the two were briefly married
and reunited for the 1999 flick "The
Messenger: The Story of Joan of Arc."
Like most of the leading cast in "The Fifth
Element," Jovovich's casting was in fluctuation,
as several talented stars were vying for
the role. According to Jean Paul Gaultier,
Julia Roberts would have occupied the lead
role in an early iteration of "The Fifth
Element." Unfortunately, Roberts, and a number of
other stars didn't get the "Fifth Element" gig.
"Oh!”
[laughter]
In a chat with Movieline, "Showgirls"
star Elizabeth Berkley revealed that
she was also in the running for a
role in "The Fifth Element," though
things ultimately didn't work
out. Berkley told the outlet:
"I got very close to getting
cast on The Fifth Element,
and Luc Besson couldn't
have been more supportive."
Ultimately, the cast of "The Fifth
Element" is perfect as it is. However,
one can't help but wonder just how different
Besson's final product could have looked with
Mel Gibson, Prince, or even Berkley
in the lead roles. Will we ever see
the iconic cast return for a potential
sequel? It's unlikely. As Besson says,
he has no interest in revisiting his sci-fi
classic. The director told ComicBook.com:
"In 'The Fifth Element,' there's nothing in the
DNA to make a sequel. They just live together,
and they're happy, and she's the Fifth Element,
and that's it. [...] It will be just
for money, and I'm not interested."